this is mind-blowing to me because
this movie doesn't come out for
another week and they're just straight up
spoiling this movie publicly this is insane
what is happening there reject nations so we are
putting this up on saturday leave a like by the
way i forgot to mention that we're putting this
up on saturday we were showing this on friday
a little bit after we did our last morbius video
we did not intend for this to be morbius week and
weird morbius newsweek but apparently the
morbius director this is approved by sony
did an interview with cinema blend and just
straight up spoiled some big stuff about the
film answered some questions clarified some
things about spider-man all i got was that
information i don't know the actual details or
what the specific answers are i was just like
i can't believe he actually did that so there's
going to be spoilers in here that's all i know is
going to be spoilers first question from cinema
blend what universe does morbius take place in
daniel espinoza apparently answered morbius
lives in the same universe as venom this is
the universe we saw venom exit at the end of venom
let there be carnage and returned to at the end
of spider-man no way home okay that clarifies
something because can't believe we're getting
these answers because before we were being told
that maybe morbius just takes place in its own
separate universe even outside of venom
so at least this puts it in conjunction
with that which could coordinate to the mcu in the
tom holland verse based off of the post-credits
scene from phenomenal garbage but it still
doesn't explain the tobey maguire spider-man suit
and it doesn't explain the andrew garfield oscorp
logo so which spider-man universe does it take
place in exactly the venom belongs in as well
now second question is there a spider-man in
venom's universe to which daniel espinosa replies
of course very descriptive they go on to ask okay
so which spider-man exists in venom's universe
daniel espinoza responds it is my understanding
that audiences will discover the answer soon okay
so at least we'll get some answers at some point
not going to be answered in this movie apparently
all right let's shift to michael keaton who we saw
in your morbius trailers is he playing the same
adrian tombs vulture from spider-man homecoming
yes what i like that the point of
this is to clarify things and i'm
i'm starting to get more confused again how
did he get to venom and morbius's universe
well at the end of venom let there be carnage and
spiderman no way home and in no way home itself it
is clearly established that it is possible for
characters to transfer from one multiverse to
another the events of no way home had the effect
of transferring venom and vulture and maybe others
back and forth between the mcu and the venom
universe okay so it's it's made quitter then
of how this all works i guess so at least in a
in a singular kind of way it doesn't seem like
they can just hop back and forth whenever
they please but yeah okay so no this just
straight up spoils and exactly how adrian toombs
is there then so after the events of no way home
adrian tombs was just planted over there in in the
morbius world which is the venom world i guess so
that's what i'm taking from this and he just
adjusted and he was just like a lot of strange
things happening i got a vulture suit now i'm
in a new universe whatever it's tuesday this is
mind-blowing to me because this movie doesn't come
out for another week and they're just straight up
spoiling this movie publicly this is insane that's
a fascinating marketing approach how did adrian
tombs get his vulture suit at the end of morbius
i just learned something brand spanking new if
you look closely you will see it is not quite the
same suit as homecoming he is a resourceful guy
just hit the ground running right when he landed
in this universe did adrian assumes his family not
come with him does he not give a [ __ ] about
him reuniting with his daughter liz whatever
his wife's name is he doesn't care about any of
that he's like no i'm gonna just plant my mark
here's fresh start starting here unless in the
venom universe this is a fresh start here literal
get out of jail free card last question is vulture
and morbius setting up a sinister six movie
well he is recruiting teammates and he has
enticed one already so it sure looks like a
start well there you go there's the spoiler for
you that they're actually going to be setting up
a sinister six movie via through adrian tombs and
apparently adrian toombs is going to be the leader
of the sinister sex and vulture will be sure i
i guess that's wrong with that i mean he doesn't
seem like he has the biggest motivation to be like
a kingpin of of you know multiversal criminals
but then again who knows maybe he's become harder
even in prison okay so what have we learned venom
and morbius are in the same universe adrian toomes
gets his suit at the end he's a resourceful guy
somehow through the events of no way home
he was transferred over to this universe
and he has decided to just roll with the punches
and stay here and start recruiting a sinister six
while he's on this version of work i might as well
double down on where i left off on the last earth
no fresh start in a whole new life as just a good
guy or whatever but no yeah gotta wreak some habit
if i'm remembering correctly in spider-man
homecoming adrian tombs he builds his suit
via chatari technology i don't know exactly how
he he built any of this stuff but these are all
the things that people would be most interested in
probably learning i'm not saying everybody i know
there's a lot of people out there who just want
to see a morbius movie and see morbius adapted and
really get the gist of that but this is uh this
is like the big these are the cliffhanger pieces
of information the things to most look forward
to after morpheus and he just straight up just
let them all out of the bag this time around why
give it a surprise adrian tube's probably gonna
break into oz corp now there you go there's some
technology there i wonder if this was part of like
sony pr being like you gotta clarify some stuff
because the leaks got out spider-man connections
are not in this movie remove stuff from the
trailer and we need to keep people excited
about this so can you start talking about how
this does tie into spider-man it is building the
bigger spider-man universe can you clean up our
mess please because yeah he's got to have like
a publicist or a pr team nearby to be like you
can't be answering that you can't be saying that
he's a director of the movie yeah so they have to
be on like on watch when it comes to these certain
things because i'm surprised by how much he just
straight up spoiled it's weird how in the last
like two weeks before this movie is getting
released how it's had the strangest press when
you look at no way home how just everything was
getting spoiled likes most of it just was getting
leaked and put out there the trailers had to do a
better job at not revealing stuff and hiding stuff
and digitally removing things and now you look at
morbius everything was fine other than the weird
situations it ran into which was through no fault
of its own i'm assuming getting the release dates
pushed back due to the pandemic but then some
rumors about reshoots and stuff and things they
maybe wanted to add in now it seems like they just
wanted to re-edit and take stuff out and then to
now put all this information out there upon things
getting revealed about no spider-man connections
it's just a bizarre couple weeks leading into
this movie that has been promoted for a few
years at this point i don't know how to feel
about any of these places this is like they've
just given up i guess well yeah it's a weird turn
from the studio who was like we don't even want
to show the returning villains and the no way
home trailers but i guess we have to and we'll
keep some stuff a secret and now this seems like
the complete opposite of that after they already
invited it upon themselves by putting in all
these potential crossovers from other universes
in the advertising like i wonder if somebody went
let's try a new approach let's mislead everybody
oh wait that really backfired okay we just got
to tell them the truth yeah before people sue us
maybe for false advertising all right guys
well what do you think about this morbius
information we learned quite a bit here yet it
doesn't spoil the actual movie isn't that ironic
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
keep a lookout for a morbius review